y
[Música]
en brasilia se conocen los resultados de
las elecciones municipales en su segunda
vuelta mientras de sao paulo el alcalde
bruno cobas fue reelegido para un
mandato de cuatro años en río de janeiro
ganó eduardo paes un ex alcalde que
durante su mandato había impulsado a su
ciudad como sede de los juegos olímpicos
tenemos reporte desde brasil
el ejército etíope afirmó que intenta
estabilizar la región del tigre tras
completar ayer con éxito la toma de su
capital mekelle mientras la crisis
humanitaria en la urbe y el resto del
territorio siguen siendo grave por su
parte el frente de liberación popular
del tigre me asegura que el conflicto no
ha terminado dice haber derribado un
avión militar del gobierno así como
haber retomado el control de una ciudad
regional
y mientras en todo el mundo siguen
replicando se los homenajes al fallecido
astro del fútbol diego armando maradona
en argentina ya está instalada la
polémica en torno a su muerte y su
médico fue imputado por homicidio
culposo
el médico de leopoldo luque aseguró que
su equipo hizo todo lo posible para
salvarle la vida y que se trató de una
muerte natural tenemos reporte desde
buenos aires
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 si revelan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en brasil donde ya se
conocen los resultados de las elecciones
locales donde cerca de 38 millones de
brasileños eligieron a los alcaldes de
57 ciudades entre ellas sao paulo y río
de janeiro el alcalde de sao pablo bruno
cava del partido de la socialdemocracia
brasileña de centroderecha fue reelegido
en su segunda vuelta para un segundo
mandato de cuatro años al derrotar al
izquierdista guillerme bolos por su
parte eduardo paes fue elegido alcalde
del río de janeiro con la promesa de
reactivar la ciudad maravillosa sumida
en una crisis económica y social tras
los juegos olímpicos de 2016 del que fue
uno de los principales impulsores y que
tocó fondo con la llegada de la pandemia
precisamente vamos hasta la ciudad de
río de janeiro con nuestra corresponsal
valeria saccone valeria la saludo muy
buena noche hablemos de estas elecciones
en dos ciudades más importantes de
brasil sao paulo y río de janeiro donde
usted se encuentra que sabemos de estos
en el río de janeiro ha ganado eduardo
paes con el 64% y la novedad es que ha
ganado en prácticamente todos los
distritos la campaña contra el candidato
apoyado por el presidente de yale
bolsonaro ha sido muy fuerte marcelo
crivella es un obispo evangélico que ha
sido muy criticado por su gestión a lo
largo de los últimos cuatro años por su
pasividad pero también por su falta de
empatía con el tipo de carioca que ama
el carnaval y que ama el samba en ese
sentido país es el típico carioca que
defiende las fiestas locales que
defiende el carnaval que es el
acontecimiento económico más importante
el de río de janeiro pero claro es una
persona bastante polémica porque tiene
varios líos en la justicia ha sido
investigado en varias ocasiones por
corrupción aunque de momento no le han
encontrado nada pero tiene varios
frentes abiertos en la justicia en san
paolo otra novedad
que recibe el 40 por ciento de los votos
bonos es una activista a favor de la
vivienda social y a favor de la
ocupación de
edificios vacíos ha sido muy criticado
por la derecha tradicionalmente pero ha
hecho una campaña electoral muy para acá
está muy didáctica y ha conseguido subir
mucho en esas elecciones y aunque haya
ganado el actual prefecto bruno cobas de
un partido de centroderecha tradicional
se considera bolo es una gran novedad en
el panorama político nacional así es
valeria muchísimas gracias entonces por
este panorama en estas dos ciudades las
más importantes de brasil como son sao
paulo de río de janeiro usted se
encuentra por supuesto vamos a estar muy
pendientes a estas elecciones y lo que
se va a desarrollar luego de estos
comicios gracias y que tengan usted una
buena noche
valeria cambiamos información el frente
de liberación nacional del tigre
considerado rebelde por el gobierno
nacional afirmó que derribó un avión
militar capturó al piloto y también
retomó el control de una ciudad de la
región al tiempo que señaló que seguirá
luchando
las declaraciones se presentan un día
después de que el ejecutivo anunciara el
fin de la operación
tras lograr el control total de meckel
la capital regional veamos más detalles
en el informe de valentina torre sánchez
las versiones encontradas reinan en el
conflicto en la región etíope del tigre
el frente de liberación nacional de el
tigre considerado rebelde aseguró que
derribó un avión militar capturó al
piloto y retomó la ciudad de acción
cerca de la frontera con eritrea yibutí
estuvo a sus las declaraciones se
producen sólo un día después de que el
primer ministro había hatch med
anunciara el control total de meckel en
la capital regional y el fin de la
operación militar que inició el pasado 4
de noviembre entretanto la televisión
estatal informó que los rebeldes
escondían armas en una iglesia de adi
vinson y los soldados federales
encontraron 70 fosas en la ciudad de
húmera
cuando revisamos el aeropuerto y el
terreno en general encontramos varias
fosas desde las patas de una chico y
oscar y un chal uno solo reciente sino
algunas de hace tiempo esto no es un
cementerio la pregunta es como propiedad
pública se convirtió en un cementerio
las comunicaciones en el tigre continúan
interrumpidas por lo que organizaciones
internacionales han asegurado que es
imposible establecer la situación real
para ver singles de sudán la agencia de
naciones unidas para los refugiados
señaló que se necesitan 150 millones de
dólares para ayudar a los miles de
etíopes que ha dejado el conflicto de
esa paz porque hay alrededor de 44 mil
refugiados que han llegado en las
últimas semanas y aunque el ritmo ha
bajado aún hay cientos de personas que
están cruzando la frontera a diario
detectar browsing de borde la
organización resaltó que no hay acceso a
las comunidades vulnerables dentro de
etiopía e hizo un llamado al gobierno
para que permita la entrada de ayuda
humanitaria y mientras en todo el mundo
siguen replicando los homenajes al
fallecido astro del fútbol diego armando
maradona en argentina ya está instalada
la polémica en torno a su muerte y su
médico fue imputado por homicidio
culposo la policía de la provincia de
buenos aires- allanó esta mañana a la
casa del médico en el marco de la causa
que investiga las circunstancias de la
muerte de maradona representantes
legales de la familia del 10 6 y el
propio maradona indi indicaron que en la
causa abierta por abrigos
de causales de la muerte se investiga
qué tipo de atención recibió entre su
última operación y su deceso desde la
capital argentina nuestro corresponsal
natalio coso y con los detalles sobre
este caso
tras la muerte de maradona florecieron
las despedidas los homenajes y los
recuerdos pero también comenzaron a
aparecer los conflictos las
controversias y las causas judiciales
como la que investiga la muerte del
astro el pasado miércoles por un paro
cardíaco en el marco de esa causa la
policía ya no este domingo la casa y el
consultorio de leopoldo luque el que era
el médico personal de maradona allí
secuestraron computadoras celulares y la
historia clínica de diego armando
maradona los fiscales están tratando de
determinar si pudo haber homicidio
culposo están tratando de ver si el
cuidado que recibió diego armando
maradona después de la operación de
hematoma subdural del 3 de noviembre
pasado era el adecuado de la operación
que había realizado como cirujano
justamente leopoldo duque el médico
habló con los medios este domingo y dijo
con lágrimas en los ojos que había hecho
todo lo posible todo lo que estaba en
sus manos y que se ponía totalmente a
disposición de la justicia
pero entonces escuchemos precisamente al
médico leopoldo luque quien dice haber
hecho todo lo posible para salvarle la
vida a diego armando maradona y que se
trató de una muerte natural veamos
yo a diego soy el que los lleva a la
clínica y pierden el foco seguimos yendo
bien en el partido que tuvo que meter en
el cuarto de él y está casi a piña con
él para llevarlo a una clínica yo tuve
un evento fortuito
un ataque cardíaco un paciente que blas
carácter es lo más común del mundo que
muera así lamentablemente
lamentablemente lamentablemente
lamentablemente es un hecho que podía
pasar como le pudo al pasante como puede
pasar después
ahí lo vean ustedes eh leopoldo luque el
médico de diego armando maradona
hablando de esta investigación que tiene
en su contra por la muerte del astro del
fútbol nosotros cambiamos de información
continuamos en eeuu porque el doctor
anthony fauci director del instituto
nacional de alergias y enfermedades
infecciosas de ese país y dijo que la
nación está en una pendiente pronunciada
con respecto al aumento de la tasa de
infecciones después de la fiesta de
acción de gracias y de cara a diciembre
coaching afirmó que había estado
recibiendo llamadas de funcionarios de
salud en todo el país diciendo que sus
instalaciones
al máximo por este por la pandemia de
ccoo y 19 también instó a los
estadounidenses a seguir usando
mascarillas evitar tocarse la cara y
practicar el distanciamiento o social
de esa manera llegamos al final del
informativo en francés de 4 continúa con
nosotros buena noche
[Música]